hello folks welcome to rational science
we have a great day today and uh we're
the only site on the internet that does
physics everybody else does
mathematics what they do is move
concepts around
mathematical concepts
we do physics we do explanations not
descriptions we also do uh extinction
i'm saying that uh we're the last
generation of humans on earth
and when we start there let's start with
extinction today
as we usually do
um
i'm going to start by saying that today
i got my
first shot my first vaccine
of covid
early
at
noon and uh
i got it because they put a gun to my
head okay
a couple months back
i went to
iceland
to visit my son
we went with my wife and we celebrated
45 years of marriage happy marriage not
too too many people get married these
days so they probably don't know what
that means
and they put me in prison i was in jail
for five days
they put me in a hotel under quarantine
and fed me but i couldn't get out
and
the three times i had to have the uh
you know the test
mouth they go all the way to your throat
and up your nose
leaving frankfurt arriving reykjavik uh
when i got there they did the test when
i got out they did the test and they did
another test in between so i had really
four tests uh not
not very friendly uh test
and uh in a couple months i'm gonna be
going to a country that
is a higher risk
so i just don't want to
you know i would avoid the hassle that's
what it is and so just get the stupid
vaccine i don't know what poison they
put in my arm just get it over with and
go on now you know
do i care about this uh covet thing am i
scared that i might get uh
you know the disease or whatever
for me it's been a non-issue for the
last year and a half that's that thing's
been around i don't care about it at all
i don't read about it the only thing
that concerns me about the covet is the
economic effect
you know the
the uh
the consequences of the
um
economic measures the draconian
measures that politicians are taking
that i'm concerned about other than that
i don't care i don't know anything about
this code
now do i believe that there's
a disease out there that's killing
people et cetera et cetera et cetera
well
the answer is i don't know
i don't know first i don't read much
about it yeah i don't care about it it's
not an issue for me uh the only thing i
can reason about it is that you have
countries like cuba
iran um
russia china and north korea they seem
to have problems as well and i don't
think they're going to work for the u.s
companies the big corporations okay i
don't think they're they're all in
cahoots with this now i think there
there must be some problem if all these
countries which are enemies are having a
problem you know within their countries
on the other hand you have this issue
where you know you have these big
corporations making a lot of money
with this vaccine and
or these vaccines they've got many of
them out there
you have a political issue for example
here in europe the uh
sputnik the i call it the spatin
the sputen
vaccine is not allowed it's not approved
and you would think that you know if
you're just trying to save lives if this
is a health issue
you know
whoever comes with a vaccine hey you're
welcome please come in and and do
whatever you have to uh to save our
population you know
and when they go in there and they say
look we're not gonna accept yours we're
gonna accept ours
they don't care about health they're
doing politics
uh and so the question is
you know you look at these things
companies making money you've got uh
this politics in there where they say
we're not going to accept your vaccine
we'd rather have ours because we're
making money off of it we don't want to
give you money
you know then it's not a health issue
it's a political issue and so i can
understand why a lot of people have
doubts
out there about you know this this whole
covet issue
um
what is it uh you know it's an issue of
information and right now i don't have
the information all the information i
need to tell you
one way or the other and again for me
it's a non-issue
talking about information we have a
little incident that happened uh that
not most of you uh are aware of
most of you are not aware of okay
and that's that they overthrew the
government of afghanistan
some hillbillies arab hill believes they
came down and took over the government
kicked the united states uh military out
of there or
force them out
you could say
is it because i'm going to talk about
politics or military issues now i don't
care about those at all
i do care about economics but in this
case i care about another issue which i
want to raise uh
in relation to extinction
okay and uh it's got to do with this
little picture here i put it on facebook
and here you see him
uh
people rushing to the airport trying to
get out of the country
uh probably middle class to upper middle
class rich people that's those are the
people that are in that c-17 airplane
others are clinging from the paint
of the airplane of the c-17 trying to
get out of there
and why am i raising this i'm saying um
i'm saying we got two issues here and
the first one is
um at the united states is a uh i'm
saying is the last empire there's not
going to be another empire after the
united states
there won't be a chinese a russian a
south american and african empire no the
united states is the last empire
and what i mean by that is
if the united states not if let's say
when
when the united states
economy collapses
that's the end of it for the world
that's the end of man
essentially okay
and um
it's not too far away
and so right now i think that uh whether
you like the united states government
whether you hate it
is irrelevant right now we have to help
the united states government not
economy right fall apart okay
disintegrate that's the first issue the
other issue has got to do with this
these people rushed to the airport at
the last moment and you might ask why
didn't they rush a month ago
why did they leave three months ago
why didn't they leave a year ago
and the answer is
information
misinformation
disinformation
how's that
i mean here you have the president of
afghanistan telling his people on the
last day saying
folks we got to defend kabul it's not
going to fall we got all the military
there everything in place to fight these
uh hillbillies coming from the mountains
we're going to defend
our government
and after he talks the first thing he
does he gets on an airplane gets out of
the country
i love that yo he needs uh again what
are you gonna give a purple heart uh an
iron cross or bravery
yeah he's gonna defend kabul from
the united arab emirates
yeah great
um this information he tells people stay
there fight
and he leaves
and
uh
so why am i bringing this up well
a lot of people don't believe
really don't believe it's not a question
of belief it's a question of
understanding a lot of people don't
understand the uh mass extinction theory
that i'm proposing
okay part of that mass extinction theory
has to do with timing with how much time
we have which is what people want to
know that's that's
a key issue people say when is it going
to happen
you know and i don't have a crystal ball
i'm not an astrologer i can't tell you
that
so the issue is you know if you
understand the theory
you might do something about it
you might take some kind of precaution
or prepare in some way if you
understand the theory and realize that
it's going to come very soon
but 90 of people probably don't even
understand the theory
uh out of the 10 remaining percent maybe
nine percent don't believe it's going to
happen in a very short time
you know that it's imminent
okay
they don't think it's imminent um
and so they they don't take any
precaution they they think it's yeah it
might happen
and it might happen in 500 years so i
don't have anything to worry about it's
not going to be on my watch
so so nobody worries about it
and they're going to end up like these
afghanis
you know they're gonna be hanging out to
the paint of the airplane
when the uh
global economy collapses
because it's gonna be very sudden it's
gonna not give you time to react or to
prepare
okay so this is the issue
and see if if
if you knew in advance uh what the
theory is about if you if you
have an understanding of the theory and
realize that it's gonna happen quite
soon within your lifetime
uh you might make preparations otherwise
you don't
okay so it's uh imagine jesus i'm jesus
christ okay i come over here and i wave
my hand and say believe in me you will
be saved you will go to heaven
okay
i'm the savior
but if you don't believe not in me in
the theory
if you don't understand the theory if
you don't think it's going to happen
very soon well then you don't take any
measures
okay so it's more or less like that
and some people have
told me said you know
let's put it this way i don't want to
live in a world without love
you know if everybody's gone
do you want to be the last human on
earth
do you want to live alone you know just
pondering you know that humanity's not
around you anymore and that there's
gonna be no future for the world and
you're just one of the last or maybe the
last person on earth
and some people say you know i don't
want to be that person i'd rather die
commit suicide or whatever
well you know that's a decision you
don't want to take today
that's my answer to that
uh see all these people they they
thought they were going to fight
kabulians
they thought they were going to fight uh
maybe they thought their city would be
defended etc etc
and when the time came they all rushed
to the airport
so at first they didn't take the
decision when they took the decision was
too late and that's more or less the
situation with the collapse of the
global economy
it's going to be very fast maybe in a
matter of couple of weeks or whatever
and then when you rush to do something
about it it's too late
and you say why didn't i think of that
whether you know and you might say
i don't want to commit suicide i want to
live
[Laughter]
so it's too late to to make that
decision so don't make it today make it
the day that it happens okay that's when
you decide whether you want to live or
not
okay so just keep all that in mind
okay uh so
here we have an idea of why
we're not going to last very long okay
and again it's got to do with the u.s
economy
here's a now analysis that came out this
week and the first is
the individual he's uh
some kind of an expert on economics you
can find his uh article out there so the
us economy has bounced back with a lot
of consumption
consumption right a lot of that
consumption is going to china
it's one of the reasons china has such a
strong economy what we're seeing is the
united states is starting to fall behind
in economic growth
okay i've been trying to tell people
that but they don't believe that well
here's a guy who at least
is on the right track as far as i'm
concerned u.s growing debt like crazy we
have debt to gdp that is fueling the
majority of our so-called economic
growth
is that growth
we'll find out
so is it really economic growth when you
borrow money or print money send checks
to people who turn around and buy goods
on amazon and these goods come in from
china
okay you see you see where this guy is
uh headed with all this okay
okay um
he goes in here let me see if we put it
on this side
says uh gdp is 70
consumption
talking about u.s gdp right gross
domestic products by the way and as the
economy has rebounded back on a gdp
basis it's done so with a tremendous
increase in a trade deficit multiple
percentage points of gdp have come from
an increase in the trade deficit and
that's not real gdp
okay
consumption is not really the economy
the economy is about what
production
not consumption
okay using money to buy stuff
and i'll give you an example and that's
spain
in the uh both uh 17th and 18th century
that's when uh their empire remember
spain was a big empire it had a
naval you know the fleet the naval fleet
uh they conquered south america et
cetera et cetera it was big
and then they started to fall apart
why because they
one of the reasons okay they got all
this gold from amer from the americas
gold and silver
and instead of putting factories
you know building something with that
what they did they used the money
especially the rich people who got all
that money they use the money to buy
stuff from where from holland from
england from france
and so what they did was stimulate
the economies of those countries up
north
and today well we know the results spain
ended up being a poor country now just
now it's coming back up a little bit
okay but
until the 19th century spain was nothing
it fell apart completely more or less
like the ottoman empire you know again
uh buying stuff being consumers and not
producers okay that's what this is more
or less about and when you buy goods
produced in asia with stimulus money
okay it shows up as gdp
but it's really uh
asian gdp it's consumption in the united
states with five million fewer jobs
because of the coven lots of women
tourism right
it shows up mathematically in the
productivity equation but it's really
chinese productivity because if you just
consume goods you're not really having
economic growth
okay
so keep this in mind uh
you can't become a consumer country you
have to be a producing country producers
is what creates tdp not consumption okay
that's what this fellow is arguing says
we are looking at a roadmap that is
clearly headed towards the us dollar
losing its sole reserve currency
status remember uh united the dollar is
the currency of the world more or less
here and there
uh
and
it might lose that status that's what uh
this uh fellow saying
the dollar has been in a series of
declining highs for decades it goes back
to the 80s for that reason i think when
we get to the next break to the lower
level the dollar is going to go past the
most recent low of around 80 and even
take out the low of 70. so i think
they're easily 25 downside in the u.s
dollar
and so uh
yeah i'm saying that the dollar is going
to lose value
and money is going to be
have no value at some point
nobody's going to want to accept it can
you imagine no one accepting the dollar
not even god you know you go to heaven
and you want to buy your way in there
and they say well no we're not going to
allow that okay we don't want your money
okay
okay so here's the uh
notion for post stimulus what we can
expect in the near future once they lift
all these restrictions okay
after my vaccine
almost any profession you ask they say
they have a hard time getting workers
okay
well no surprise people are making more
money or the same amount of money by not
working okay well we're all more or less
in tune with that we know what's going
on out there so what will happen when
these stimulus programs ultimately end
or people actually have to start paying
for their rent
okay
and uh and so he says there's going to
be tremendous economic disruption okay
people are relying on stimulus and the
stimulus is going is responsible
completely for this economic growth
okay so uh
what's going to happen after the
stimulus stops
will people go back to work
will they want to work
i mean they got used to the easy money
they say hey i kind of like that it was
like retirement i had all this time on
my hand
government sending me the check i'm
consuming
uh stuff that's made in china
okay
something is wrong folks
and i'm not sure the united states can
come out of that so easily okay
and again if the u.s economy falls apart
china is not going to replace it because
if the u.s dollar for example or the
economy goes to pieces
europe goes to pieces and china will
have no one to sell
to so china won't grow either
and military i don't think china will
the u.s will not allow the chinese to
you know match them militarily so uh you
know there's gonna be a problem in the
world and that's just coming up maybe
five six years at the most
okay so once again all i can urge you is
to
think about these things
think that at least it might happen
and to take whatever measures you can
you don't want to be rushing to the
airport at the last moment okay like the
kabulians
okay um here's another bit of
information so social security could be
insolvent within eight years no it came
out today
okay and so for those of you who are in
your 20s and 30s whatever
maybe you think
you're going to get some social security
uh retirement money
uh i would say think again i don't think
it's going to happen not for you guys
okay
okay here's another bit of data came out
today also uh or i think yesterday data
from the 2020 census released earlier
this month shows that the united states
has become significantly more urban in
the last in the past 10 years and i've
been saying that for a while now that
you know urbanization is taking place
there's this transition from the country
to the city
not only in the united states the entire
planet you choose the country you choose
the country everybody's moving from the
country to the cities
from the farmlands to the cities the
farmlands are falling into the hands of
big corporations agricultural
corporations which mass produce the food
and feed the cities that's the way it's
working
can this process continue endlessly to
the point where everybody's in the
cities
and the countryside is only in the hands
of the big corporations
so the more this transition proceeds
uh the more people are squashed
into the cities
the fewer people they're going to have
because in the cities you can't have
children and so you have that
situation where
population doesn't grow
because you have everybody concentrating
in the cities
the cities uh the dollar is falling the
euro is falling the money is is becoming
worth
less not worthless but it's worth less
okay
and at some point you can't even reach
the end of the month or barely
there's no disposable income that's got
to have an effect on the companies that
produce goods and services
and it's all intertwined
okay and we cannot escape this process
there's nothing we can do intelligence
cannot
overcome this technology cannot overcome
this the the fact that uh we can foresee
events we can't do anything about this
okay
so um
yeah uh it says uh the population u.s
has increasingly is being increasingly
concentrated in cities
so we have all these uh things going on
okay
uh this is what the density map looks
like of the united states you can see
that it's not evenly spread out you can
say that just about any country in the
world but what's important about this is
that
no new cities
will be founded
we will not create new cities in russia
in japan in china no new cities okay
this is the issue
uh so all these countries that whatever
city you see on the planet today
essentially those will become bigger
everybody will
simply
rushed to the cities from the
countryside to existing cities
there's no way you can create a new city
we're not in the age of colonization
anymore okay so whatever cities you see
on the planet today that's what man dies
with essentially maybe one city here
there might be founded you might find an
example out there you know i i can give
you a couple examples of that not not
really
founding new cities but enlarging little
villages and turning them into more than
towns and cities one was where i spent
my prison term in eloy evo if you look
at the city of eloy it was nothing until
the 1990s
then they built the prison
and suddenly you know all these services
started uh coming around the prison
system the federal prison that was there
same thing happened you can look it up
uh to
this uh city where
florence in colorado where they have the
adx the
most maximum security prison in the
world it's built underground so that you
cannot escape
and
again a city that grew with the prison
system
and that's another reason that the
united states
uh does not like to legalize
drugs because it uses that
remember most of people go to prison
today maybe up to 85 percent i would
think judging by what i saw
are in there for drugs
and so imagine if they were to legalize
all drugs
well then they they would get rid of the
entire prison system
okay there would be any prisons
and what if we do it in reverse what if
we raise the penalties
um
to those who deal with drugs who traffic
with drugs
well then you need prisons and you put a
prison and around that prison all these
services pop up out of nowhere
so one way to found cities today is
through prisons
okay that's what i'm trying to say here
okay but you can't do that all over the
world and it's not it's not really gonna
create a population boom
it's just a little drop of water in the
ocean essentially okay so
yeah we're going to die with the cities
we have on the planet today okay
okay so these are some of the things i
look at or think about when i'm looking
at the global economic collapse
specifically the u.s united states
economic labs i look at inflation
decline in real wages okay our real
wages maintain the debt to gdp ratio
stock market crash or you know uh is
there going to be a stock market crash
will it be the last one the next one we
have would be the next to the last one
you know these are the
the issues i look at cryptocurrency
volatility you know lots of
cryptocurrency lately uh
new business people are at home they
receive these
government checks they have a hundred
dollars maybe here and there and they
say
i'm at home this is so easy i just open
an account and invest in
cryptocurrencies
and
essentially it's gambling
okay it's gambling from home you don't
have to go to las vegas
uh or uh what is it
you know atlantic city you don't pull on
the uh one-arm abandons anymore what you
do is you play the stock market
play from home
okay so a lot of people getting into
that
uh especially with the money that the
government gives them not very good
because this totally unproductive stuff
again okay
unemployment i look at that
uh protests and riots
you know you got to look at the how many
riots we're having now lately in in many
countries okay that's another
um
thing in the barometer that i look at
you know a
condition out there of the
uh social uh
socio-political
uh
state of mind
you know people want to go out there and
protest for whatever because they're not
very happy with many things okay so the
more of those that we have it's it's a
signal
it's um it's a clue that something is
not right okay
uh this information
tremendous this information we had all
the information we needed we could
probably i mean if you had all the
information you needed to make a
decision on whether there's going to be
gover a
global collapse economic collapse or
even a collapse of the u.s economy
then maybe you would act differently but
you don't have all that information at
your
fingertips and a lot of that information
is this information
do you think the government's ever any
government for that matter is gonna tell
you panic panic the world's coming to an
end we have no solutions
to our economic problem do you think a
government would say that
no they say exactly the opposite they'll
always tell you the opposite
everything's okay folks go back to work
we're doing fine we're going to get out
of this mess
that's what they tell you
and so they blindside you to the
realities okay
and it's going to happen like the people
like the kabulians
you know they were blindsided to what
was really going on
you know you had the united states and
the taliban you know they had meetings
behind the
essentially your secret meeting or
behind the backs of the government of
afghanistan they reached a deal there
and i'm sure a lot of people in
afghanistan did not hear about any of
that
and so they were saying they were comfy
at home saying well everything's gonna
be all right
and everything wasn't all right because
they lacked the information and the same
thing with uh with if there's going to
be an economic collapse the government
will not inform you
that there is going to be an economic
collapse they're not going to tell you
look the dollar is on its way down we
can't do anything about it all you have
is private people like this gentleman
who uh i quoted just a minute ago uh
they'll tell you but you know some
people believe him other people believe
others uh some people are bearish others
people are bullish you know say you got
all kinds of people out there
and and so you know people are not aware
of the reality okay or the realities
okay
and yeah look at also chinese economic
growth is china growing and
what i say there in the case of china is
that china used to grow at a much higher
rate it was growing like uh when deng
xiaoping took over the government it was
growing at like 25 percent
uh annually and now it's down to six
five maybe and that's uh
if you believe the chinese numbers
okay uh
so uh
again you gotta be careful with the
disinformation very important point
because based on that you take your
decisions and you have your beliefs
and you got to be very careful about
what information you have out there
today okay so
just be on your toes
okay
one fellow says here says economic
collapse has a cause and it isn't
because a species disappears because it
is too old
well he's got it wrong
that's not what i'm saying at all i'm
not saying that economic collapse has
anything to do with
species being old so you know one more
time i want to get this straight here
you have it mass extinction has to do
with economic collapse it's got to do
with the overturning of what of the
ecological pyramid
background extinction is that's that's
where the species ages and aging is what
overturning of the population pyramid
not ecological pyramid but the
population pyramid and the loss of
genetic diversity
okay
so i just want to make sure
people
understand
what the theories are okay and the
theories are um
mass extinction has to do with food with
economic collapse
and uh
and um
background extinction which is the
extinction of a single species
that has to do with the aging of the
species meaning
population pyramid overturn and genetic
loss of genetic diversity
okay so at least get get the
theory right okay it doesn't mean you're
gonna believe in it means that you got
to get it right so you understand what
i'm saying here okay
okay uh another foul
says that uh all these mass extinctions
happen because of catastrophic events
which is the
party line is what all paleontologists
out there essentially believe
it says historical context indicates
cataclysm as one of those environmental
changes that cause extinctions yeah
historical no that's the paleontology
world believes that you can only produce
mass extinctions through
uh cataclysms or catastrophic uh
acts of god okay
large ball lines uh tectonic and
volcanic etc etc and the geologically
obvious worldwide flooding events have
no idea what he's talking about maybe he
thinks uh all this has to do with the
bible biblical
flood
i have no idea what what this fall could
be referring about worldwide floods i
mean floods never killed a single
species
so i'm not sure what he's talking about
when he says floods
but and i don't think there's any
paleontologist that talks about the
flooding of the world okay so i don't
know where he got that
okay but uh this is my take on this and
that's that catastrophic
uh or catastrophes never and uh caused a
single extinction
catastroph catastrophes have nothing to
do with extinction
nothing at all so you have the
ordovician uh
one of the theories of prominent theory
is that a supernova
nearby caused the uh you know there was
a gamma ray burst
and
apparently uh one of the theories
because there's some theories there one
of the theories is knock the air out of
the earth
you know like uh
what is it the foghorn leg corn you hit
him in the stomach and all his feathers
come out of him and then come back
and that's more or less what these
people are saying you know they're
saying
um you know the the
uh
zap the gamma ray burst
hit the earth knocked the air out of the
earth
killed all the animals that had to die
and then the air came back
that's one of the theories okay and
who's behind this nasa
why because nasa wants you to believe
that all catastrophic theories
uh are true and they have to do with
uh extraterrestrial
impacts or
causes okay
permian uh there's a couple theories
there one is that you have volcanic
activity another one is that you have
methane
sprouting out of the sea beds
filled the earth created this uh
uh
winter this uh this cloud that prevented
uh sunlight from reaching the uh the
plants
so the plants die the herbivores die the
carnivores die
um
yeah the the only problem with all these
theories including the cretaceous one
which is the asteroid impact
is that they cannot explain
selectivity the only thing that a an
extinction theory has to explain
and the way they do it they have an ad
hoc sub theory for every
uh different types of animals how did
the uh flying reptiles die well they got
hit with all these burning stones is
this um
these uh hot stones that came from the
explosion how did the animals in the sea
die well it turns out that the asteroid
fell on a pile of sulfur
and that sulfur acidified the water sun
animals could take it some could not and
those that could not die
and they have all these sub theories
to explain how this guy died not this
other guy died and they cannot explain
even with that
no
no catastroph no catastrophe ever
caused a single extinction okay mother
nature doesn't use catastrophes to
to do extinction the way mother nature
does it is
the natural way she what she does is she
goes in there and she says look
we're going to deprive you of food
now if you're deprived of food will you
die
and i think the answer is yes i mean you
might think that you might live but no
if i deprive you of food at least for a
year i think you will die for sure
and if we deprive any animal
even plants for that matter with a food
for at least a year will that plant that
animal will die
and so at least we have a mechanism we
can all understand no food you die
period we're done
now the question is is that how mother
nature works yeah if the
food source in this case the plants that
live for millions of years disappear
because they go through their population
pyramid overturned
they've been around for too long they
lost their genetic diversity
the plants are no longer there the ones
that the herbivores depended on and
establish a long-term relation with
yeah those animals will die
and the hurt and the carnivores that
depended on them will go with them
meanwhile you know while other plants
are expanding at the expense of those
plants
and you have these little animals that
depend on those plants those thrive and
those become the new next generation
of plants and animals that uh
dominate the planet the landscape
so that's a more rational theory than
saying that you know an asteroid hit the
earth or that
uh
you have a supernova with gamma rays
that bombarded the earth
uh that that only gives job security to
nasa okay and they do have a special
interest in that that's why they use
those funds to
fund
uh university researches uh that
highlight extraterrestrial causes
right
okay um
here we have another issue fell says i
thought the more evolved the less
genetic diversity
yeah that's true and uh that's what my
graph showed here's the graph again from
my book okay uh the more you go forward
in time
the more that the
animal is evolved
and the less genetic diversity there is
okay so that is what what i'm saying so
i'm not sure
what this fell understood if he's
questioning
he's putting it in a negative way like
if that's not what i said yeah that is
what i said okay that
the more evolved the species
the less genetic diversity and today you
know we have very little genetic
diversity among humans okay and part of
that the reason for that is that
um
you know we've been in breeding for so
long
we we don't breed with
gorillas or chimps which are closest
relatives today
the last time we could have bred with
someone was probably neanderthal or
maybe florence's or one of those
uh cousins
and no we we just bred within ourselves
and today we're washed out that's what
it is okay so
what little mutations we collect year
after year from one generation to the
other is knocked down through um
completely through
um what is it the true bottlenecks
uh usually diseases wars so on uh that
wipe out suddenly big chunks of our
population
and then we have a smaller
founders effect we have
streamlined our genetics and now we
start all over again with fewer people
and if you do this over and over again
that defeats any
little mutations that you collect day
after day from one generation to the
next
so
no in the end we we
lose genetic diversity any species loses
genetic diversity yeah usually through
disease
okay another issue fellow says anyone
who claims genetic diversity increases
by inbreeding uh obviously hasn't raised
dogs or other domestic animals look up
animal husbandry folks and yeah if you
go to that site that he
points out there you'll see
what the issue is and they write the
following says the canine diversity
project is an attempt to acquaint
breeders of
domesticated dogs with the dangers of
inbreeding and the overuse of popular
sires
both lead to the
indiscriminate what loss of genetic
diversity okay
you can't inbreed because inbreeding
results in loss of genetic diversity
and people don't all understand that
especially people who are geneticists
they don't understand that
they think we increase genetic diversity
because we have all these mutations from
one generation to the next
and it's like they don't understand that
a species any species can only lose
genetic diversity over thousands of
years essentially you know you can lose
lose lose lose you're going to win a
little bit here and then you lose
because of bottleneck and founders
effect you win a little through mutation
you lose a lot through bottlenecks and
founders effect
and so yeah
no geneticist has figured that out to
this day
another issue
raises
says i thought modern plumbing was the
cause of conquering most disease along
with food standards and things like that
uh yeah i agree um
that that is true as far as i'm
concerned at least uh if you look at the
fishy the
history of england
in the 19th century one of the things
that
preserved the population uh why uh
so many children were dying at the
beginning of that century and very few
died towards the end of this century or
a lot less
was the sanitary conditions you know
they cleaned the fans the tams uh the
river
um
and they uh started vaccinating people
if that helps maybe by then we have
already had already collected
uh quite a bit of defenses against
common
diseases uh childhood diseases and so
you know at some point those diseases do
not kill they just they're endemic but
we survived them a child gets sick but
doesn't die
again once he doesn't die he passes
those
beneficial genes to the next generation
okay so that's the theory whether you
believe it or not that's a separate
issue but that is the theory
okay another fellow raises an issue says
we should segregate groups of people in
strongly divergent artificial
environments where the original genetics
and the new mutations will be selected
differently with enforced fertility and
child health care create novel and
populist populations
species of man
uh
yeah
that's been proposed by
many people in the past politicians etc
first of all that's politics i don't do
politics in other words i don't do
recommendations in the sense uh this is
what you should do or
any of that i don't care about that
at all i try to explain
causes and mechanisms
and so what we should do
is is not part of this channel
you know it's
that's up to every person to
decide what they should do all we can do
is present our case theories or whatever
now you know this thing about selecting
uh doing artificial
insemination and prefer preferential
insemination um i don't think you're
going to create a new species anyways or
uh
all you're going to do is what this
other fella said about dogs all you're
going to be doing is perpetuating
inbreeding and inbreeding is what
loss of genetic diversity
so all you're doing is guaranteeing that
we're going to die
maybe sooner than later okay but again
humans will not die because of loss of
genetic diversity i want to make that
absolutely clear people
are confused about that about this
channel no we're going to die in a mass
extinction that's got to do with food
it's got to do with economic collapse
okay
nothing to do with
i can't say nothing to do with aging
it it does have to do with aging in the
sense that our economics depends on
demand and demand is a function of
population and if the population doesn't
grow it does affect our economics only
in that sense okay other than that we're
going to die because of economics and
whatever i mean by that i'm saying that
money will be no more
we won't believe in money we won't
accept money because it will have from
little to no value
and when that happens not if but when
that happens corporations that produce
the food and distribute to the cities
have no more incentive to do so
that's the theory okay
okay um
one final comment person said uh when
are you going to make
uh uh how to survive extinction video
i think he said it in fun uh but still
uh i'll address the issue
i'm saying there is nothing absolutely
nothing we can do about extinction the
extinction of our species
it's guaranteed it will happen no amount
of foresight no technology no
intelligence
those are not antidotes we cannot do
anything about extinction okay so i just
want to make that absolutely
clear
okay let's move on to our physics uh
segment okay today we're going to be
talking about specifically about opacity
we've had uh wet reflection we had
transmission we had refraction today we
do a little bit of this dull
subject called opacity why are things
opaque
not really why uh what i want to explain
is the mechanism of
all four of these you know um how does
light work
when it reflects when it uh
goes through a transparent medium
uh how does it
refract and why
or
how it produces opacity that something
is opaque
you know you can't see through walls you
can see through glass
and even if though you see through glass
when you see like through water well
you get that
pencil that you put in the water it's
broken in half you know and why does
that happen uh
what's going on there you know
and so all these uh issues have to do
with how light behaves
and
in order to do that you got to
understand a little bit about light
especially what the hell is light
what is this thing we call light
okay that's that's essentially what what
we need to get uh our
wrap our mind around and the issue here
is that uh we have to contrast what
mathematical physics is like versus what
we do in this channel which is the rope
model okay there is a difference a
significant difference i'd say
completely different difference
what does quantum say specifically but
it applies to relativity and strength
theory as well well they deal with
particles
and when they don't do particles they do
waves and when they don't do waves they
do particles or wave packets
they do discrete
uh
one-way mechanisms
okay that's essentially it because even
the wave is taken to be a packet
okay
uh you know the way they chop it off and
you say well holy what came before the
wave what comes after the wave
they chop the wave and they say here's
the wave
and you see it from beginning to end
right in front of your eyes
i thought the wave extends all the way
to the edge of space time
so why do they chop it off
is the wave choppable
i mean
if light comes out of an atom originates
in an atom
and let's assume it's a wave transverse
wave
especially when it travels because the
uh notion is that
it departs and arrives as a particle
because that's when you detect it but in
between it travels as a wave as a
transverse wave okay meaning
it's transverse motion up and down in
perpendicular to the direction which it
travels
okay fine so what are we talking about
what is this wave wave of what
and because they never figured it out
they said it's a wave of nothing that's
more or less the party line
and so we're not dealing with physics
anymore because now we're talking about
a ghost we're talking about a spirit
that is waving
so we need to get a handle on what is
light okay in order to be able to
give you a physical interpretation of
how light behaves during reflection
refraction uh transmission in the case
of trans apparent medium and opacity
okay
okay so one fella says and this is more
or less the
what most people think out there okay
that's what they have in the backs of
their minds says uh something is
transparent if the photons what
passing through it
everybody thinks of this photon passing
through a medium okay
are not fully absorbed that is their
energy
look at the words he uses cannot or is
not fully absorbed by the electrons in
its substrate
it may bend the light bend the light how
do you bend the light
okay
look at the wording okay as water does
or absorbs certain wavelengths absorb a
wavelength what are you absorbing what
is a wavelength
wave of what
wave of nothing so how can you have the
wave of nothing how can you absorb
nothing okay it may reflect some of it
back and again all this is the nonsense
that comes from mathematical physics
they learn these words by wrote
like poetry you know you recite
and we have nothing in front of us
because we don't have a
what is energy energy is a concept a
mathematical concept what is a
wavelength wavelength of a wave what is
a wave what is a transverse wave waving
of what
of nothing and so so far we have nothing
in this whole so-called explanation this
notion this individual has
and this is what the majority of people
think out there who are in physical or
mathematical physics
they think you know that it's got to do
with absorbing energy absorbing
wavelengths
we have the wrong language to begin with
we cannot understand this and all this
is based on the planetary model that you
see there where you see the electron
bead the blue electron bead orbiting
the atom you don't like orbiting fine
you can say it's here and there and
there you don't know where it's at it
doesn't matter all we have in front of
us is a red ball in the center
supposedly the proton and a blue ball on
the outside called the electron so we
have one
ball next to another ball that's what
you have you have a tennis ball or a
golf ball next to a bowling ball
so what keeps that electron ball
bead
tied to the
proton bowling ball
why does it fly away spontaneously why
doesn't fall to the nucleus so unless
you can explain that you don't have a
model and all this that the spell said
there falls apart completely we can't
talk about energy we can't use the word
wavelength because we're not talking
about anything physical up to this point
okay
and this is where it starts we start on
the wrong foot we start with the wrong
language another fellow says
says uh light goes through the walls of
my greenhouse
uh
no
light does not go through because if if
light goes through you're talking about
particles or waves there's no such thing
as waves i guess then that leaves
particles it turns out that according to
the religion of quantum mechanics there
are no such things as core puzzles the
so-called particle is an equation a wave
function or whatever they call it they
got all these synonyms for it but we
don't have a physical object in front of
us so you cannot talk about traveling
through
and even if we remove the roof
of your uh
of your greenhouse
light is still stopped by the atoms of
air
light does not go directly to your
little plant
it has to go through all this air that's
in between the sun
and your plant
and people think that light is a little
ball that just goes through this
these gazillions of atoms remember the
air covers are all planet it doesn't
stop here where we breathe it goes all
the way out there almost to outer space
we have a very thick layer of air
covering our planet thank the thanks to
that we can breathe
and here's this little photon it's going
through all these atoms of air and other
garbage that's floating around there
and reaching your little plant right
through
the glass in your greenhouse
man that's a
that's a mighty photon right a little
photon ball or or wave
that can go through all these atoms
okay is is that what's really happening
and uh
so what do we say to this well uh we say
this that's
that this is the worldly wisdom it's
misleading uh intuition
okay you think that's what's happening
because you think that life is coming
directly to your eyes
without anything being in between there
and you forget that all that stuff that
you're breathing is between your eye and
whatever you're looking at and it's like
you're saying well it's going right
through there well what do you mean it's
going right through it what is going
through there and is it going through
there
and so the question is is that what
mother nature does okay
and that's why in science uh because of
this misleading intuition we don't rely
on eyes meaning observation we don't
rely on hands experiments and we don't
rely on testimony meaning evidence none
of those are part of science those are
all part of religion in religion we
observe in religion we do experiments
and in religion we present evidence to
convince the jury because we're we're
targeting their belief
in science we don't do any of that
science we do thinking because we're
trying to understand the mechanism that
mother nature uses to do these magic
tricks
and so we rely on reasoning and you have
to be able to explain the cause in other
words make a movie of the mechanism only
then can we understand what you're
talking about and only then can we
visualize the mechanism
you can only visualize a mechanism
if you um
put objects there you know i give the
simple example of you throwing a thumb
through the window
and i film it i show you the film and
you know how the window broke you say
okay how did the window break well
you're not going to use words like force
and wave and energy now you're going to
see a rock went through the window
and we don't care how strong the window
is we don't care any about all those
mathematical nonsense that have nothing
to do with the question at hand i just
want to know why the wind why the glass
is on the floor and you say a rock went
through the window that's how we explain
it in physics very simple baby-like
kindergarten-ish we understand it and
that's what we need to do with light
the only reason we don't do it with
light gravity and magnetism so on
is because we can't see
the mediators that's the only reason
you can't see or touch the mediators
you can't see the mediator of light you
can't see you can't touch it you can't
see the mediator of gravity or touch it
you can't see the mediator of magnetism
directly with your hand what i mean you
know you can see it with iron filings uh
for that matter i can see the mediator
of gravity too uh you know uh by
throwing the pencil and i say well it's
gravity yeah but how did it happen so
you can't see the mediator any more than
you can see the mediator of magnetism as
well
and if we cannot see or touch the
mediators it is useless to go to the lab
and do an experiment you're not going to
figure this out through an experiment
we've done all the experiments we ever
need to do
especially like for gravity or light
here's the experiment for gravity this
is all you need to know
that's it the only experiment repeatable
okay let's do it twice
a repeatable experiment you let go of
the pen it falls to the floor now you
tell me what caused the pending fall to
the floor
and hopefully this is kindergarten stuff
i mean really kindergarten stuff mother
nature is a very simple woman she
doesn't do any sophisticated mass he
just deals with objects you just have to
figure out what came in contact physical
contact with the skin of the pen
once you figure that out we're done it's
it's simple stuff it's baby stuff
that means there's something here that
we can't see or touch
that is coming in physical contact with
a pen the pen is aware of it but your
hand is not
okay that's what we're saying here okay
so all we need to do is make visible the
invisible stuff once we do that it's
kindergarten stuff it's like if i throw
the stone through the window but you
don't see the stone and i just move my
hand and the window breaks and you say
how did you do that that's magic yeah
it's magic only because you didn't see
the stone
okay but if i
make a movie of it and visualize
visualize it for you in other words i
show you the stone
that's stupid stuff i mean
any kid can understand that you threw a
stone
it's only because you can't see the
stone that is so magical
oh how did you break the window and this
is no different than that
the only reason you think this is
magical is because you can't see the
physical objects mother nature uses
to perform this magic trick
okay
you can't see what's in contact with
this physical with this pen
that's it that's the only issue other
than that it's it's kid's stuff once you
can see that mother nature god or the
devil whoever comes over here and shows
you
the invisible mediators that they use
that stupid stuff that's ridiculous
it's baby stuff it's kindergarten stuff
the only reason it's magical is you
can't see or touch the mediators no
experiment
done in the lab will ever elucidate
the invisible mediators for that you got
to drink a beer sit back
and visualize think use your brain not
your hands
okay
okay so uh here we have uh
uh the
waves and this person thinks or these
people because there's many of them they
think that these waves go through the
walls
and i'm saying you know uh waves
particles whatever you want they don't
go to wall of bricks wall of glass wall
of water or wall of air
so if some of these are transparent it's
got nothing to do with going through
okay because for that first of all you
have to identify the the mediator and
you can't use the word wave because wave
is not a mediator okay you gotta in
physics you've got you have to
absolutely identify the physical object
okay how do we do ropes well they're
there it's very simple you know you have
these ropes and what these ropes are
doing they're attached to atoms
and so
i have shown all the atoms here
obviously and we have a rope attached
for example to that water
block there
it's attached to one atom there and that
atom is attached to another one and
another one and another one until it
goes all the way to the other side and
that's why you can see through water
okay same with air and same with a glass
window
okay
so uh this is what you have to keep in
mind okay this is this is uh
you know once you identify
the mediator in this case uh the
electromagnetic rope that's a piece of
cave you say okay one atom is attached
to another one stimulates the other one
you have these
torsions going from one atom to another
and now you can see what's happening
what's happening is a relay mechanism
it's not that i can see you directly
through the air
it's that
whatever light is going back and forth
is going through each one of those atoms
from one atom to the next atom to the
next atom to the next atom to the next
atom
at the speed of light why because
there's no
nothing really traveling
back and forth
what you have is a torsion if you want
to call that torsion travel
you know you're be my guest but it's
it's totally in in situ
and so because it twists in situ it can
go very fast speed of light and because
of that all you have is the this whole
row of
uh
ropes one attached to the next atom down
her own and i can see the window because
of that because you know the rope
carries
that signal
that torsion that arrives at my eye
so it's not that i can see the window
directly
as these people think that there's some
kind of photon
bead
uh point particle that's coming to my
eye and hitting my
eye which is the notion that we've had
for what
10 000 years now
no there is no little particle that's
traveling to my eye the reason the
mathematicians chose that is it was
easier to model
even to this day
their equations based on a pin point
they can put a
what they're looking at is
they can model that with an equation
that tells them something about position
as they call it
location of that particle and they say
okay this particle's here now here here
here here we measure we know the speed
that's what they're talking about
but they don't know you know it's like i
say it's uh they did all this math
on fish and ocean
and it turns out that mother nature
works with eagles you know or
birds and air
so all their equations are applied to
the wrong
objects into the right medium
wrong to the wrong media okay
you can do all the equations you want
unless you identify the physical object
all your equations are in vain
okay because again
you might think that there's a little
trickle a little
sequence a little a little series of
particles reaching your eyes
and it turns out that those so-called
particles that you're
describing with your equation
are really a rope torquing in place
okay so it's very different mechanism
and so what is your equation worth if
you're applying it to the wrong
invisible entity
this is this is this is where we have a
problem
okay and so um
this is what i like to say that
he who proposes a physical mediator for
light has the burden of illustrating the
mediator that's the first thing you got
to do okay you can't just say a wave did
this and a point particle did that no
please illustrate your stuff first then
begin your talk if you cannot illustrate
especially your atom
or your
particle of light if that's what you're
going to propose or your wave of light
and tell us what what is that mechanism
or that entity that's there in front of
us if you can't start there you can't
even start your talk we take the
microphone away from your mouth okay you
got a lot of work to do you got to go to
your dark basement and brainstorm until
you get a physical entity we don't have
an entity yet you can't do physics
you need an entity to do physics okay
in explaining what causes the their
medias to travel rectilinearly if you're
going to use the particle model why does
it travel in a straight line
i mean
like explained a couple weeks ago
you look at yourself in the mirror
and straight ahead
and you say well is that really true
well you know they you can take a laser
and run it through lenses
and it's a straight line
i mean you can do that sign as
scientifically as you want as they say
you know you can go to your dark
basement and point it at mirrors at
lenses or whatever and you'll verify
that light travels in a straight line
how is that possible with discrete
particles when the entire world entire
universe is moving
the earth is moving right now around the
sun i know some people the flat earth
don't believe that
but uh
you know here you shoot these photons to
the moon you know the laser ranging and
the earth moves so did the moon and so
what all these particles what uh
traveling curves
especially a long warped space
so now you
how do you explain rectilinear or
straightness
uh with
discrete particles that's one of the
things you're gonna have to explain okay
because light does travel straight light
never curves around the corner okay and
people say yeah it does no no it doesn't
you know you do it all with straight
lines okay you don't you don't have
light
curve around corners
and some people don't understand that
that that's why again people have been
misled by their intuition okay that's
what they think is happening okay what
is a substance causes the mediator to
bounce during reflection
you know why does that particle come
back to you in one case and you know in
the case of transparency you continue
straight through the the substance i
mean if
if the photon is going to hit an atom
why does it bounce in one case
reflection why does it go through it
transparency in another case
okay and so they have to go through all
this rigmarole where they say well you
know in one case it absorbs the energy
the wavelength in another case it
doesn't
so they have to go through all this uh
mathematical wording
that has nothing to do with physics and
we want to see the physical
entities we want to see you
illustrate bouncing and going through
okay and that's where you gotta say well
the ping-pong ball
hit the
proton bowling ball in the atom and
bounced back and then in the acely case
it went through
how do you explain all that
okay
what causes the mediator to stop uh
be absorbed in other words during uh
opacity
what causes the mediator to go through a
transparent substance yeah okay and
explain why the mediator of light
swerves and continues to travel
rectilinear uh through a substance
during uh refraction remember when it
goes through water or sometimes through
glass depending on the substance you
know uh light curves you could say right
it bends
not curves it it goes it's a straight
uh deflection
and then it continues straight it's not
like it's curving you know no no it's
straight here and straight here
straight straight straight straight it's
just that it's like bent chopped you
know broken at that point
it's not a smooth curve
so you gotta explain this you can
explain how that photon suddenly hit a
brick wall and then went in off in a i
don't know a 30 degree angle or whatever
that's what you got to explain
and then of course they cannot explain
that
they they just tell you what the angles
are
they say we we measured and we measured
the angle and this is the angle i don't
care about your angle i want another
mechanism
so angles is not going to answer the
question a snell's law and so on not
going to figure it out
okay so we have one
group of people and they're prominent
they're known as how stuff works i
mentioned this the other day
and what they say it's got to do with
more atoms and fewer atoms and they say
light waves run into very few atoms
few of them referring to the atoms when
they shine through air
so
the people here and how stuff works they
believe
that it's got to do with how many atoms
there are okay
uh the more atoms i guess the less you
can see
is that the theory
okay
[Music]
let's look at this
let's find out if that's true okay
and here we have the situation
here you are
and you're looking at the window during
the day okay and you can see the window
perfectly well
there's a sun shining out there and
you're just staring at the window okay
so far so good now what happens towards
the evening or as the day progresses
suddenly you know the sun goes down and
everything starts becoming reddish
okay so suddenly you don't see the
window as well as you used to
and by the time you reach night time you
can't see the window at all
okay now you can barely see the window
so what happened here uh suddenly the
window disappears why is there are there
more atoms between your eye and the
window is that what happened
god put more atoms there at the end of
the day
and you don't have to wait till night
time i mean
you can do this uh with a lamp
you know you turn the
lamp off maybe at night you know and
it's everything's dark you can't see the
window you turn the lamp on now you can
see it
so
when you turn the lamp on
there are fewer atoms in front of your
eyes from your eyes to the window and
then when you
suddenly turn the lamp off
more atoms come in there now you can't
see the window is that what it is is
that the theory
[Laughter]
talk about the ptolemaic explanations
that's
how stuff works uh they should be kicked
out of science that's what they should
be doing that's what we should do with
them
okay so uh
i ran an experiment
with my dear wife
and here it is uh
it's a polarization okay
and when you have these two polarized
lenses if you turn them at 90 degrees to
each other
you have opacity you can't see through
them on the other hand if they're both
aligned like you know horizontally then
the laser runs right through them
through both of them you can see the
laser at the uh
at the screen
okay so
uh
did we put more atoms in between them
when we turn them around
or is it or does this have to do does
this opacity and transparency have to do
with the location
of the molecules or atoms or whatever
okay so that's the first question for
you
um here's a
another experiment we did and this one
was with tape
you take tape and you turn it around
and it doesn't stop light like the
lenses did you know these are not
polarized what you have is a tape a
transparent tape you run a laser through
it
we didn't do it too well not very
scientific but that doesn't matter i
guess you get the idea you can do it at
home just take a laser and point it
two pieces of tape transparent tape okay
cellophane
and just put the tapes at 90 degrees to
each other and then again
turn it around and you'll see that it
doesn't stop the light at all okay so
the fact that you turned
one tape 90 degrees to the other doesn't
do the same thing as the polarized
lenses
okay
that's what i'm trying to say here
okay uh just in case we did it with a
plastic box that i had there okay and
here it is let me put this make this a
little bigger
okay and so here you have light going
through this you could use glass you can
use in this case i had this plastic box
which is handy
and if you shine through this plastic
box you can see it doesn't stop the
light
like the whether you put it at 90
degrees or not it doesn't
uh become opaque
okay
that's the point okay but in the case of
the polarizing
lenses yes
it does
block it does
become opaque
just by putting it one at 90 degrees to
the other okay so when they're
lined up like you know both up and down
light goes through it's transparent
suddenly you
turn it around
and now it's opaque
um
it sounds like to me that's got to do
with the molecules that make the
material
what do you think
okay
i don't think we put more air molecules
between the two lenses because we turn
one around
okay so this
uh this to get you thinking about this
okay
okay uh let's continue here uh here's um
polarization according to quantum
mechanics okay
uh they say that when you turn it around
uh and this was uh flannel's explanation
the 1820s
and what he said is you know when you
turn one of these polarizer or
polarizing materials
uh sideways
what you're doing is blocking
part of the signal of light
and today you know they've improved upon
and they say well you have this electric
field in this magnetic field that make
up the
wave the transverse wave of light
that we don't know what it is
so they use these words they say it's an
electric field and a magnetic field
unfortunately the word field refers to a
mathematical concept that just says
bunch of numbers that's all the field is
and so it doesn't help us much but we
still have a problem even if we concede
the field
as a physical object
we're going to say that it's a physical
object we have one which runs at 90
degrees to the other
are we saying that by putting this
picket fence there which is what this is
called this explanation by putting this
picket fence we are eliminating the
magnetic field in this example here and
only the electric field is what goes
through
can light be made only of an electric
field
okay
so the
vertical in this case apparently
uh chops off the magnetic field in this
specific
instance right we're talking about a
single beam a single
uh wave
and what these people are saying is that
the picket fence put it 90 degrees to
the other one
blocks out
one of the components of
light
and that's in this case uh the magnetic
field
which means only the electric field got
through
and what they're saying at that point is
that that light that you see there
going to the second polarizer
that's only made out of uh made up of
an electric field
so um
yeah the question is whether you accept
this explanation
because this is what these people are
saying they're saying that only one
component of the transverse wave got
through
okay
okay um i think we need to figure out
in order to understand polarization
in other words right uh
it goes light goes through it the the
two films are transparent right and you
turn one of them around 90 degrees and
suddenly it's opaque
light does not go through
okay it gives us an idea that
something's related to the molecule but
then we got to see what
these molecules look like maybe even
what the atoms look like
unfortunately we don't we only have
bird's eye
visions of uh atoms some people say oh
we filmed and we've photographed and et
cetera et cetera
imaged uh atoms
only from a bird's eye perspective give
me an atom anyone that you want look it
up uh through google whatever google uh
images whatever
and what you'll find is bird's eye views
you see a ball
a bunch of balls
that's all you'll see
well that
doesn't look very much like a little
bead going around
what it looks like is a ball it looks
like this that's what they look like
this is not a little bead going around
so what quantum proposes for their atom
which is
the orbit tulle
what is an orbital it's a region where
you can find the little bead
that's not what you see what you see is
a membrane
you see a ball
okay
that's the first issue
but even assuming that you know we we
need to know what these atoms look like
okay
and these are the images that we have
again they're not pictures they're not
movies uh that we filmed
it's uh these are images that we make
artificially okay and this is what
carbon looks like more or less they have
the little beads going in there okay
you'll see that in a second here
uh the beads are going around because
that's the quantum version but really
the carbon atom looks like
uh membrane
that's that's at least what we propose
and that's the what chemistry uses
not what physics uses in other words
mathematical physics but they use the
little bead but the chemistry and the uh
version we propose are exactly the same
in this sense we're talking about
membranes what you see there okay
here's the same one
for oxygen okay this is oxygen again
they have the little beads going around
and
because they want to talk about
electron beads
and what we're saying is that's not what
an atom looks like an atom looks like
you know the membrane that's on the
outside and those membranes are made out
of the threads that make up the rope and
that later on will make up the atom
itself so this is what the atom looks
like that's an oxygen molecule according
to us okay
okay uh so
if that's what the uh oxygen atom looks
like if that's what the carbon atom
looks like what we're proposing okay
um
we're going to apply this to calcium
carbonate
calcium carbonate is the material that
they use one of the materials that they
use for these polarizing or polarizers
these polarizing materials okay
so here's what uh the atoms look like
each individual atom apparently looks
like again i can't put my hand on the
fire i can only go by what these people
have picked up over the years
and it looks pretty much like the ones
i'm proposing anyway so i have no
problem with them and here's what what
they look like
here you have the calcium on the left
hand side and it's a big atom compared
to carbon and oxygen
and what you're staring at there is
three levels of s you got s1 s2 and s3
which are the balls the round uh
spherical balls and within that you have
the p
orbitals which are those
extensions that come out of the s shells
okay
and so uh calcium uh looks more or less
like that
carbon is a little simpler oxygen a
little more complicated than carbon but
that's more or less what you have uh the
constituents of the calcium carbonate
[Music]
molecule
okay
and when you put them together this is
more or less the appearance of the
calcium carbonate
let me get myself back in here
this is more or less what it looks like
it looks like a little gingerbread man
okay you have the calcium on the top
okay
you have the oxygen uh
atoms
the p orbitals merged
with the calcium uh atom and also with a
carbon atom two of them
one merge with one and the other one
merged with the other and then you have
a third oxygen
atom uh at the other end so this is more
or less what the calcium carbonate
molecule looks like and that's what
we're going to be using to build
our
polarizer our polarizing material
and it's got to be oriented now i
oriented it as a gingerbread man it
could be sideways for all we know okay i
don't know that all i can do is
go more or less by what we have so far
today again we haven't seen the molecule
itself we don't have a
photograph of the molecule so all we can
do is speculate and
uh more or less try to visualize what
this molecule looks like okay
so let's build one line
of these gingerbread men okay these
calcium carbonate and here you see it
okay this is more or less what they look
like we put one next to each other again
i put them in this direction you don't
have to put them in you can put them
sideways for all i know you know we
don't really know or or you can look at
it from the bottom upwards for all we
know i just put them in this direction
arbitrarily just to make my point
okay there we have a line okay this line
of uh
calcium carbonate atoms okay let's uh
build a little more we're going to build
a little wall now okay here we see the
wall okay several
layers of this okay let's assume that's
what we have uh in one of these slabs of
calcium carbonate okay
and now we're gonna connect them we're
gonna connect two of these walls with uh
the ropes and we're gonna just connect
one rope because obviously there are
many ropes
imagine
each one of these atoms you can you have
to think of them as a bunch of hydrogen
atoms for each hydrogen atom that can
constitutes carbon for each hydrogen
atom that constitutes uh oxygen uh we're
talking about one rope
okay so we're we're just going to put
one rope and here's what it looks like
more or less let me get this one out of
the way
okay
and we're gonna put a rope from a source
it could be a laser
to that first atom and from those you
know you're going to have a series of
ropes connecting all these atoms and
then it's going to connect
those atoms to the wall behind it okay
and from there on
further on now here they're aligned you
know the gingerbread men are all aligned
in the front with the ones in the back
and so light goes through it's
transparent
the material these two slabs are
vertical
okay
and they're both and they're transparent
you shine the light through it goes
right through
okay so far so good
now what are the possibilities here what
what are some of the variables that
we're going to look at to try to
visualize understand what's going on in
front of us in this magical invisible
intangible world of mother nature what's
going on in that world okay that's what
we're going to try to
see if we can visualize it we can
understand it okay that's that's what
i'm getting to
and here is uh what i think is gonna
happen here when you switch one of those
around okay
and you can see here they were straight
and light goes directly from one slab to
the other now we're going to turn one of
those slabs around 90 degrees look at
what happens to the ropes
okay they're no longer straight the ones
that were going straight now they're no
longer straight
okay so i think this is one of the
factors you should consider when you
analyze what's happening with a rotation
of one polarizer with respect to another
and again what we're talking about here
is that suddenly what was transparent
became opaque
okay do we understand ourselves okay
this is what i'm saying okay
so just by rotating all you did was just
change the location of existing atoms we
did not put more atoms in there like how
stuff works
alleges
so it's not like we put more atoms in
there okay
and
those people who say well the wavelength
was absorbed or the energy was absorbed
well all we did was switch them sideways
why would the electrons now not absorb
those same photons
so is it a question of just absorbing
energy absorbing wavelengths
whatever wave is
obviously there's something more
involved here it's got to do solely when
we went from transparent to opaque
all we did was change the location of
the atoms same atoms you just switched
them around somebody what was
transparent became opaque
okay we got that
okay so um that's one of the things you
got to consider
what's another one
well here's my magic rope okay
and i'm going to do this sideways so
that you can see what i'm talking about
okay so here we have the rope okay and
one
one of my fists
is a source the
or you could have the polarizer here and
the other polarizer over here as long as
they're um
aligned
they're both up and down so to speak
then you have the normal torsos okay
normal torsions coming from the laser
what happens when you turn one of them
around okay that's what we're going to
look at
so i'm going to turn one of these around
and you can see what's happening
suddenly you have a
quarter wave
quarter link
that's offset with respect to this here
it was like that and now when you turn
it around
you get a different uh frequency a
different
link length
okay you see what happened just by a 90
degree turn of my hand
okay
so what i'm saying is um
these are the things you have to
consider when you're looking at at least
from the rope model when you're looking
at these slabs one of them is that the
ropes are no longer
straight ahead okay now this rope is
turned with respect to the other rope
over there and the other one is that
you're also twisting the rope okay so
these are two factors you
have to consider
when you um when you try to explain when
you try to understand what may be
happening in there okay not going to
tell you exactly what's going on in
there i'm not going to tell you that i
do know okay all i can do is give you a
theory on the one hand and i can give
you on the other hand
um something to look for something that
you can
uh test with your mind and find out is
this possibly true
that you can rationalize it and you can
reason it okay you can't do that with
anything provided by quantum mechanics
okay
now let me throw another
variable here just to drive you nuts
completely nuts okay
um
uh here we did an experiment with my son
uh ons
and
uh you know you can turn the slab
uh of uh calcium carbonate you can turn
it around
and the atom now uh is in a different
location with respect to the first slab
so if both slabs are you know like
parallel there and you turn one of them
around whichever
well uh you know what you did is the
atoms
the molecules or the atoms that
constitute the molecules
now they've moved sideways
you know they moved at 90 degrees
so here's the million dollar question
okay listen carefully
can you do that with oxygen air can you
do that with h2o water
okay and let me show you the experiment
we did with my son okay nobody asked
this question in a million years so here
it is for you for the first time
uh my son turned the water around
now you can see that little uh plastic
uh dime there and plastic uh coin
and
it does move from horizontal to vertical
is that what happened with the atoms
that make up
water
is that what happened with the molecules
that make up water
did they also turn around
or did gravity continue to pull on those
molecules in the same direction
whether you turned it around or not
okay
let's be more specific so that you see
what i'm talking about okay
here you have
an atom uh an atom of uh
sorry a molecule of water okay let me
remove this one here for a second
okay here you have molecule water okay
let's assume that because oxygen is the
big atom okay
uh oxygen is made up of eight
hydrogen atoms
okay it had to be squashed in the sun
under pressure to make that oxygen atom
so uh
what do we mean by that means that eight
ropes are coming out of that oxygen
uh
atom okay but that's not important for
what i want to say right now i just want
you to be aware of that whereas the
hydrogen only has one rope oxygen has
eight ropes okay so that's got to be
understood
oxygen is tied to the center of the
earth according to the rope model
okay so or the hydrogen we're just going
to make an assumption here assumption
no proof no evidence
assumption we're going to make an
assumption that
it's the uh that the molecule of water
is positioned in that direction with
respect to the center of the earth
okay
so when i turn
the water around okay and here we're
going to turn water around okay
please bear with me here
is that what happens to the water
molecule are we
uh turning it around or does it remain
in the same position as it you see it on
the left-hand side there does the
oxygen continue to stay
downwards when you move water around
okay so this is the question before you
okay
here's a
bunch of water molecules okay is that
what happens
or is this what happens look at these
two pictures you'll see that there's a
little difference
okay
in one case
water turns around because you turn the
whole glass around in the other case
the water molecules remain
in the same direction with respect to
the center of the earth because gravity
pulls them in the same direction in
other words there is no change
in the location of the molecules as it
is in the calcium carbonate uh crystal
structure okay
hopefully you understood what i'm saying
here that we have a difference between
calcium carbonate
which is in a rigid crystal structure
you move it sideways now you've moved
those molecules those atoms in a
different direction does that happen
with water
how about with air okay let's look at
air now okay here's air okay here's the
air molecule i put two oxygen atoms okay
so there's your air molecule
does this air molecule stand up like
that
that's the question for you okay
and you can see that uh when you turn
air around
if you can do that you'll grab it here
and just turn it around
okay is that what happens to the
molecule
assuming you know the the two oxygen
uh atoms are more or less parallel um
parallel or i guess
tied to the center of the earth in a
symmetrical way
can you unsymmetricalize them can you
have one oxygen atom be closer to the
center of the earth than the other
or
whichever way you move your balloon with
the air inside it
uh the atoms in there adjust their
position with respect to the center of
the earth to gravity
which way is it okay
and again here it is uh this is one
version and this is the other version
which one is true
okay i hope you understand what i'm
showing here in one case
uh the atoms change their location from
horizontal to vertical and the other one
they always remain horizontal
and that's what i want to show here okay
so those are the questions for you okay
i don't know if you have an answer for
for those questions but uh these are i
think the things that you have to factor
and uh one of the things that you can
use this for is to destroy the flat
earth okay and
flat earthers never listen to they keep
asking the same question over and over
they never listen to the answer and they
just keep asking the same question over
and over they say how is it that you can
curve water let alone air
and so now we have an answer for them
for those of you who are listening the
flat earthers don't listen so they they
don't know what i'm talking about here
but here it is okay
uh every atom is connected to the center
of the earth or to every atom on earth
so it doesn't matter but the center is
the center of everything everything is
pulled towards the center okay and here
you see it the water molecules are all
pointed towards the center of the earth
okay now we're going to put the ropes in
there okay we're going to attach the
ropes to all these atoms and molecules
first the water molecules and now you're
going to see the air molecules okay
and so now you can see why
water curves around the earth and why
air curves around the
spherical earth
hopefully a spherical not a disc
as it is in flatland
okay so uh yeah um
i'm saying that
the atoms
have to follow gravity somehow
you cannot isolate gravity from our
atoms i don't care if it's oxygen i
don't care if it's well
meaning air i don't care if it's water
they have to be pulled towards the
center of the earth and if i rotate my
bottle of water
does the water stay
like in the case of the calcium
carbonate
crystal structure flabs whatever
okay that's the question for you
and yeah and that's food for thought
okay for you to ponder before we can
move on to other subjects in the coming
weeks but here's a good old mother
nature and yeah what she does is she
spends the whole day just
knitting her ropes
okay
okay let's go with uh
let's go with uh some of the questions
some of the issues people raise here
okay uh
questions since last time comments that
people made okay
so let's move on with these uh one fella
says
ether is a bunch of particles
[Laughter]
you don't even know what you're
criticizing okay sorry uh ether theories
and particle theories are only infamous
for being total
theoretical enemies and you couldn't
even get that part right
okay
for your information ether is oh let's
find out let's find out what ether is
okay ether in any theory about it
uh is a field
a field and all in uh permeating fluid
okay so uh he this fellow uh thinks that
a field is a fluid
and he visualizes some kind of i don't
know uh oil or
water or something like that some fluid
maybe air
that is floating out there in space or
that space is
this ether this fluid space itself is it
so one of the two and they never answer
the question uh some people because you
have different opinions there some
people think that ether is something
separate
from space
that ether is contained within space as
if space were a container
that's got borders i guess or maybe is
infinite okay because if it's infinite
the ether is infinite
and then it's not an object because all
objects are finite because an object is
that which has shape
so we got a problem there but uh yeah
they haven't resolved whether ether is
something separate from space or space
and ether are identical it's the same
thing
in which case we got a problem because a
fluid is made out of discrete particles
that's why it's fluid according to
at least the
mathematical version of it and so
we need to identify what those particles
are what are those little balls that
make up this fluid this field
that's what we need to figure out but we
don't even need to go that far here we
have a definition of the word field a
region of space
is a region a physical object absolutely
not region of the hand like for example
the palm
is not a physical object the only way
the palm becomes a physical object is if
you cut off the fingers and just show
the palm then it's a physical object a
standalone physical object otherwise the
palm is a region of the hand china is a
region of the earth
there is no region
a standalone region region is always of
something else and so if that's what a
field is according to the definitions
that are out there then we have a
problem and then a physical quantity
that's how it's defined okay and what is
it represented by a number that has a
value for each point in space and time
so uh this well says that uh he wants to
do it with a field that's what he says
that a uh ether is
and all we can tell them is that there
is no such monster as a field
there's no such monster as
a region
and uh essentially field is just a value
at each point in space it's a
mathematical constant
okay and so you can't say ether is a
bunch of numbers
no ether is a bunch of particles that's
why he refer to it as a fluid and here
it is okay let me put it on this side a
bunch of numbers that are vibrating
that's a field
is is that what ether is
okay so
yeah people who propose the ether have
no idea what they're talking about
because they never defined the ether and
if they defined it then they screwed up
anyways because if you can define the
ether it's not an object you don't
define objects in physics we point to
them define we define concepts if ether
is a concept you can't use it in
physics so the only way to
show the world what ether is to point at
it for that you have to illustrate it
uh point to um
a site that you know of where you got
the ether and maybe upload it to your
own site and we want to see what the
ether looks like
don't don't define it because if you
define it you're lost already okay
you're not doing physics
you can't you can't use words
as objects that you defined
you can't use the word table if you're
going to define the word table we don't
define the word table in physics we
point to it
we point and say table now you can do
whatever you want with it but if you say
well let me tell you what a table is
it's a
a
a board that's got four legs that's a
concept that's not a that's not a table
table something else in physics
okay another fella says uh why is the
sky blue well blue highlight frequency
gets scattered by the molecules in here
again uh they think it's all this um
particles floating around
that's what they've been taught or they
might think it's the waves
uh one way in all their in every sense
they don't they don't realize that
what they're trying to explain because
when they talk about absorbing frequency
or absorbing wavelength
what they're talking about is again
relay
they're not talking about going through
okay and so they don't realize this okay
says the other frequencies don't or
hardly interact with air and go straight
through
this is the notion people have and again
it's because they do experiments instead
of doing thinking
and science we don't do experiments in
science we explain them okay
and so
that's what i
can say to this fella okay here it is
irrational to say that frequencies
interact
irrational will say that frequencies go
straight through notice physical object
this frequency okay in science in
physics
it's what happens when irrational folk
fall
fail to identify the objects that
mediate phenomena you can't talk about
frequency as if it were a physical
object say frequency does this and
frequency does that
now no mention the object that does this
and that not the frequency frequency is
a property of an object if anything
okay
frequency is what is known as an
adjective really in this case an adverb
okay there is no such noun as frequency
in science in in ordinary speech yeah
it's a noun in physics it's not a noun
okay
frequency was something does
it's an adverb yes
until you identify the object in your
theory you haven't said anything so this
poor fellow he doesn't have really a
an explanation he just repeated what he
heard out there and uh without
understanding what he was saying
another fellow says uh there is a change
in velocity of the light
only when i'm drinking too much beer
okay
light never changes its velocity it
always travels at little c no matter
through what medium
why because it doesn't travel at all
it's a torsion along a rope that extends
between any two atoms
so there is no
traveling through
and there is no such thing as this speed
all you're doing is changing
one uh
parameter for another you're saying that
the more links that you have
the smaller they are
and the fewer links that you have
the longer they are okay and that's what
c equals frequency times wavelength the
wave equation states okay it's so that
equation that that you're staring at
that's the equation of a rope there is
no other object that can uh
simulate that maybe or maybe a chain but
it's got to be a chain a rope something
along those lines okay and in the case
of a chain you can't do that either
because the links are of a certain size
with a rope
the links become smaller the more links
you have for for a given length of rope
do the experiment at home always in the
presence of a relativist very dangerous
experiment just take a rope and twist it
okay
okay and uh phil says a wave is a
perturbation
what is a perturbation
is that that's a verb so you're saying a
wave is of earth yeah
wave is a measurable result
uh
and he says noun
no result is not a noun not in physics
that's in ordinary speech in in religion
not not in physics in physics there's no
such physical standalone object called a
result and only physical objects qualify
as nouns for the purposes of physic you
cannot use as the subject of a sentence
a verb
not in science in ordinary speech you
can do whatever you want but not in
science what is waving are the mediums
listed above and he mentioned water air
light and magnetism so what is light
what is magnetism what what kind of
medium is magnetism
those are properties or
events or things that happen these are
happenings these are occurrences
phenomena
there's no physical object called
magnetism there's no physical object
called light really
okay you can talk about the rope which
simulates light you can even talk about
particles for that matter meaning core
muscles right you can talk about that
and say look
light is mediated by particles yeah
that's fair game in physics okay but you
can't say that uh um light itself is a
physical object light is a result light
is what we call that phenomenon okay
so you can't use the word light really i
mean officially
informally yeah you can you can do that
but not officially when when you talk
officially in physics you gotta identify
the physical object
okay
shape is the only assumption made
besides location
shape and assumption so everything
physical should follow from shape alone
says
a lot of people had problems with shape
this time around and this is the just
the first guy okay and so this is what i
gotta say what does this even mean what
is this valve possibly blabbing about
what do you mean by shape is an
assumption
what does that mean
in physics the assumption include
objects definitions the statement of the
facts okay
that's that's what an assumption is it's
known as a hypothesis no such
monster as shape is an assumption
okay shape is an adjective not a noun
shape is a property of an object so you
cannot treat shape as a noun in physics
which is what this vowel is doing here
he's talking about shape the theorist
presents the objects and defines the key
words and shape is neither a key word
nor an assumption we do not use the word
shape in physics almost at all the only
time we use the word
shape is to define the word object and
the only reason for that is to
distinguish it from what the
mentally [ __ ] mathematicians
call an object which is that which has
which can be seen or touched
what people don't understand all these
people who harp on the word shape
is uh
the context they don't understand it
they don't understand they don't
understand and so what i need to do
sometimes if i can reach it
is bang them with my
uh
dough roller
over the head okay now people who use
the word shape or who attack the word
shape or who want a definition of the
word shape are mentally [ __ ] people
okay i'll state it again they're
mentally [ __ ] people because they
don't understand the context
so let me explain the context let's see
if you understand that maybe i don't
know maybe i'm wasting my breath and my
time
the context is that the idiots of
mathematics
they define an object as that which you
can touch or that which you can see
then they go to the lab and they say
let's go and see if we can touch
or see
gravity let's go to the lab see if we
can touch or see the mediator of light
let's go and see we can touch or see the
mediator of magnetism
that's the problem and when they go
there they can't touch or see light
gravity or magnetism
and so they say huh
and that's when they start introducing
concepts such as field and
wave and
zero dimensional particles
and they turn these into physical
objects they talk about fields and who
knows what
and so what we're saying is
and this is the only context in which
you're going to use the word shape and
then never use that word again in
science is to define the word objects so
that we compare
the criteria we're saying that shape is
not the same thing as c or touch
that's the end of it don't ever use the
word shape again don't ever bother with
the word shape again or i'm going to
beat you with a with my dough roller
okay anyone who hops on the word shape
means he's a mentally [ __ ]
individual who doesn't understand the
context the context one more time just
so it goes through
is we're comparing shape as a criterion
against
the idiocy of mathematics which talks
about see and touch
that's it we're done no more never use
the word again
okay shape is what you learned in
kindergarten if you missed kindergarten
well then go back there you should go
back there and they'll show you what
shape is any little kid will show you
what shape is you don't need to go to
university to find out what the
definition of the word shape is
they can show you a ball and they can
show you a cube and say the difference
between these two things is the shape
we're done that's all you need to know
you got it or are you still mentally
[ __ ] okay
let me make that clear
anyone harping on the word shape is a
mentally [ __ ] individual who does
not understand the context
period we're done okay never mention the
word shape again or i'll treat you with
the respect that you deserve
okay here's how the same file says the
shapes are identical
and see they're going through all these
nonsense because again they they want to
get to the bottom of the word shape
because they're mentally [ __ ]
individuals okay the shapes are
identical in the case of tangible
semi-tangible and intangible and yet
they the reaction is different what the
shape have to do with tangibility
what does shape have to do with
tangibility these people
are off on a
tangent
tangibility
they're off on a tangent worrying about
the word shape
you know
totally mental retardation there's
nothing more that you can say about this
they don't understand the context okay
what does the spirit cause whatever it
is the scalar value from one to zero
tangibility chart what does one and zero
have to do with shape
these are mentally [ __ ] individuals
who don't understand
nothing
they're really completely lost i don't
know what these people are doing in
physics they should be in religion okay
because they don't understand the
context and so this is what i answer
what the shape have to do with
tangibility what the shape have to do
with reaction what the shape or
tangibility have to do with ones and
zeros
okay so
i don't know what these people are what
they have going through their tiny
brains i don't know what these people
really have
in their minds why are they happy in the
word shape what the shape have to do
with anything
all we're doing is comparing the word
shape against
touch and c which is the current
standard and when people say oh you
could define shape so i'm going back to
by default right to see and touch to the
lab to see if i can see and touch light
if i see can see and touch gravity
that's what they this is what they have
going through their minds
okay so that's why they harp on the word
shape it drives them nuts no we don't
use the word shape we use the word
object in science and the word object is
not the word shape shape is a property
of objects shape is an adjective not a
noun
in physics
in religion
they use it as a noun we don't care
about that in physics shape is an
adjective
it's a property of an object
and so i don't know how to draw that
point true i mean
it's a waste of time sometimes with
these people okay
it says tangibility is a concept
uh not this magical third category
called attribute that you sometimes
bring up the only concepts that i know
about are relations between shape
relations between shapes what the hell
is this person talking about
okay and so here's my answer shape is a
is a static property
uh
attribute characteristic of an object
adjectives are used to qualify shape
okay
in physics adjectives are static
concepts
shape is the only universal property of
objects it is irrational to talk about
relations between shapes
it is irrational to talk about distance
between adjectives okay it is irrational
to talk about sizes of
or orientations of or distances between
adjectives in physics rationalists
compare objects not adjectives
rationalists compare sphere versus cube
not spherical versus cubic spherical and
cubic are adjectives sphere and cube are
nouns
okay and it takes a religious individual
or a mathematician
uh 10 years to understand that
so yeah you don't compare cubic against
uh
you compare objects
not shapes
there's no such thing as shape
shape is an adjective
so i don't know how to drive that
through
okay again more shape here more shapey
stuff
shapes have concepts like distance
poor vowel orientation direction even
size
size of shape
size of spherical
size of triangular
orbital orbital i mean he probably
missed kindergarten i really think he
did you know so well this is what i have
to say about that and say shapes don't
have possessed concepts shape physics
has nothing to do with size
which is math
circular and triangular have no size
there is no such monster as distance
between shapes there's distance between
objects okay there is no distance
between cubic and spherical because
these are adjectives those are the
shapes
there is distance between cube and
sphere which are the objects okay
orientation and direction are observer
related characteristics
okay
so uh
they don't have to do with shape they
have to do with your location with
respect to something the observer could
be the object itself okay
corollary
never use the word shape as a noun in
physics okay object is noun shape is an
adjective never use the word shape as a
noun
okay the only time we use the word shape
is to compare it against the idiocy
proposed by mathematicians
and that is their their
notion that an object is that which you
can see or touch no those are not the
criteria
because we can't see the air
okay
and um
and so is that means that air is not an
object here the the air blew your house
down but it's not an object it was a
spirit it was nothing
okay so something is wrong with the
definition that the mathematicians have
been working with for the last ten
thousand years
and just in case we have another
individual he says sorry can you tell
everyone the definition of shape again
[Laughter]
mental retardation that's what this is
uh you said shape is what distinguished
the inside of an object from the outside
of it and we treat both the inside and
outside as object then you said shape is
the inability to blend with the
immediate surrounding or environment
i wrote that in my book yes
that's not a scientific definition
that's so that you know what i'm
referring to in ordinary speech
we don't need the word shape in science
okay now
but let me get to the bottom of this uh
what these mentally [ __ ] individuals
have the problem they have
uh and here here you see it
we have three uh four words that define
the word object that which has shape
now the first question is why didn't he
ask oh what do you mean by that
or what do you mean by which
what do you mean by has i mean are those
words any easier to define than the word
shape
and then the other issue is do we have
to define every word in the dictionary
and then once we define those we got to
define every word that we use to define
that word as well
so we're we're off on a wild goose chase
just defining words all day long because
the guys are well what did you mean by
this and what did you mean by that
no we don't do that in science
in science we don't have to define any
of those four words okay we had to
define the word object because
mathematicians
define it as that which you can see or
touch so we had to define
uh what an object is in the alternative
if it's not c and touch
and so the only universal property of
all objects you know all objects have is
shape
it's a property
and properties
in physics are adjectives so shape is an
adjective for the we say spherical
we say triangular we say cubic that's
what shape is and
what i mentioned is adjectives
okay
and so i don't know how to drive that
point through but i'll say something
else
regarding the word shape
and that's that all these people what
they do
is they play dave devil's advocate to
extreme
levels and they say well you can't
define the word shape
meaning that by default
they go back to the mathematical
world where it's c and touch
so i turn the tables around on them and
i say okay
define c
define touch
can you define those words any more than
uh
you can define shape
and so i'll define shape the day you
define c and touch how's that for a
for for a
championship for for a contest
okay how's that
yeah i'll define uh shape when you
define c and touch
okay
no we don't need to define c touch or
shape not to any high degree all we need
to do is choose a criterion to define
the word object we can't do physics
without objects because if you replay if
if you don't use objects to do gravity
magnetism light or electricity or
whatever
then you're in effect
introducing spirits
into your theory
you're saying that it's done by black
magic
that's why objects are absolutely
necessary in physics and because that's
the first
what i call the golden rule of physics
or the golden principle that you need an
object to do physics
the first word you need to define in
physics is the word object
the only other
i could say there's a word before that
and there's the word definition itself
you need to define what a definition is
and we've defined all these words we
define what irrational is uh we define
all these words because we need to get a
handle on the language can't continue
using words like field and energy
anymore wave
okay a fellow says uh so if i roll a
rock down a hill it's uh magically
becomes a concept and not an object
absolutely
you just said it okay the rock is an
object before you do anything with it
after you roll it you are referring to
the action and not to the rock
so action is a dynamic concept
yes so once you roll it rolling rock is
not a physical object a rock is an
object not a rolling rock a flying eagle
is not a physical object an eagle is an
object
uh
swimming fish
is not a physical object a fish is an
object okay i
get the hang of it okay
and so yeah here we say rolling rock is
not an object rolling rock is a movie of
a rock in motion many frames of a film
do not qualify as a stand-alone object
for the purposes of physics an object is
a finished product it could be a picture
drawing snapshot statue etc
an object that is
uh
an object is that which i shape not an
image in motion shape is a static
concept there is no motion embodied in
the word shape okay
again it's an adjective all adjectives
in physics are static concepts uh
dynamic concepts are known as adverbs
okay
so if you talk about rectilinearly
you're talking about motion
and rectilinearly is an adverb
okay uh
and again uh it's not the language of
ordinary speech
okay so unless you get in tune with the
language you don't know what you're
talking about you're you're talking
about the word motion you say well
that's a noun
well that's that's a noun in ordinary
speech not in physics and physic motion
is a verb
okay we got that straight displacement
bird
okay so uh these are not nouns in
physics
and this is where the problem is where
people have the wrong language
they start talking about motion they say
well the motion of jupiter
no no in in physics we say jupiter moves
moves is a verb
we don't say the motion of
okay
the orbital or the orbit of jupiter no
no we don't say the orbit of jupiter we
say jupiter jupiter orbits
orbits is a verb not a noun okay
can't be turned into a noun in physics
because we lose track we we're talking
nonsense then
okay foul says plasma is an electrically
charged gas which is a concept then
later says meaning me right
uh gas is an object oops is gas a
concept or an object well gas is an
object okay and plasma is a dynamic
concept there's no physical object
called plasma because in order for there
to be a physical object it's got to be
static i should be able to take a
photograph or make a picture of it you
can't make a picture of plasma
and here's proof evidence
let's introduce it into court so that we
convince people
okay gas i can take a picture of i don't
need to know what it's made out of i
don't need to know if all that gas is
made out of little particles none of
that here you have a static image of gas
plasma plasma you have to ionize the
atoms
in the picture and you can't do that
yeah the only way you can have ionized
which is a verb okay
is by removing according to quantum
right removing an electron from its atom
or putting one in there in case of
positive ions right
and so if i remove if i have to remove
remove is a verb okay
i can't put the word remove in a
photograph
remove requires a movie and a movie is
never a physical object it's always a
dynamic concept we're talking about a
swimming fish we're talking about a
flying eagle we're not talking about an
eagle we're not talking about a fish
okay so again it takes a religious
individual 10 years sometimes never to
understand
the difference between a concept and an
object gas is an object plasma is a
concept sorry okay destroys the electric
universe entirely electricity itself is
a concept not a dynamic concept really
uh not a physical object there's no
physical object called electricity okay
and what are the idiots of the electric
universe always say
they say very simple bill
put your fingers in an outlet and find
out if it's a physical object
uh no that's not the way we determine uh
if it's an object okay we don't we don't
go in there and run a test
run an experiment of any kind
in science we define what an object is
if it meets the definition it's an
object if it doesn't it ain't
see how simple it was
and these people say no i want to run a
test to find out if it's an object i
want to see if i can touch electricity
well can you touch the table that's on
the other side of the universe
and if you cannot touch that table on
the other side of the universe is that
table an object
you couldn't touch it
can you see it you can't see it so you
can't see or touch it is a table that's
in cling on land is that a physical
object
and so yeah if
you can't answer that question it's
because you have no answer you your your
definition of your criteria of c touch
dies right there
okay that's what it is
okay uh file clarifies there good
clarification the phrase made of implies
more than one object okay he's talking
about meteorology here
and so cannot be applied to the
fundamental or a single piece object
if
a table is made out as far as physics is
concerned is made of a single piece
and it's not made of parts
any object in physics that you point to
and name for the purposes of presenting
the object is made of a single piece we
don't care what it's made out of you
point to gas we don't care if it's made
out of little atoms that's not the issue
we know that in real life uh gas is made
out of particles just like a table is
made out of particles we call them atoms
we call them molecules fine
when we look at the word table we're not
thinking
what it's made out of how many atoms are
in a table making up your table we point
and say table we treat the table if it's
made out of a single piece
when we put the gas it's made out of a
single piece that thing that you see
there whatever it is that's made out of
a single piece
okay we point to water we say water
we're looking at the whole body the
whole shape in front of us we treat it
as if it's made out of a single piece
okay so no meriology and that's what
this fall is saying therefore it is
irrational an irrational question to ask
what a fundamental
elementary right object is made of
right
and i guess he's referring primarily to
the thread the single thread and we're
saying that the single thread that makes
up all matter and all
interconnecting ropes
is what underlies all objects the thread
is not made of discrete particles it
cannot be made of discrete particles
first of all because the reporter would
say uh what's it made out of
and what are you going to say well yes
made out of all these discrete particles
and what is each discrete particle made
up
and the thing is forever and ever and
ever and ever and ever forever
no at some point the bug has to stop and
the bug stops at the elementary
fundamental entity the thread is a
fundamental entity it's not made of
anything it's not made of parts it is
flexible despite that it's not made of
parts it's made out of a single piece
despite that it is flexible it has the
properties of a river at the same time
it has a property of
a brick wall or a steel beam steel beam
for all practical purposes we say it's
made out of a single piece because you
can't bend it okay and in that sense
the thread is made out of a single piece
at the same time the thread has the
ability
to be flexible
which is what a river is or molasses is
or a string is
and so people say huh how can that be
because again you're applying
properties of the physical macro world
in which we live every day you're
applying it to mother nature's
elementary fundamental entity which is
the thread you can't do that
the thread
has a property
that
matches our macro world which is like
the thread that you use for sewing or
maybe
a rubber band okay so the thread looks
more or less like this
that's what the thread looks like
now how complicated was that okay and uh
it doesn't stretch like a rubber band
because it's made out of a single piece
but it is flexible
those are the assumptions
the assumptions the word assumption
those are the assumptions that we
applied to the thread in order to
understand the theory
am i getting through to anyone there
okay and uh one fella says final
question or issue are there any
empirical tests that we can be that can
be performed to test the rope hypothesis
my god poor fellow
uh they have this thing that you got to
do experiments
and they go out there and do experiments
and you know when i was at amd we before
we could do an experiment we had to run
through the engineering manager because
doing experiments costs money
and so you have to justify it and the
way you justify you do a design of
experiment something no one does out
there especially nasa doesn't do any
design of experiment
what they do is they just run their
experiments so they ran their
gravity probe b experiment they send it
out into space and they say oh we proved
that space is not only warped but you
can rub your
uh your shoulder or your elbow against
space
that's what they prove with their
gyroscopes well
before you can
do the experiment be nice if you
designed it meaning make sense of it on
the bullet on the blackboard
and
what you got to show is what space is
what is this space-time thingy
please draw it
if you can't draw it you can't even run
your experiment because you don't have a
design of experiment how can you prove
that space
uh pushed
your
uh gyroscope
if you cannot show what space is
so they they're making an assumption a a
ridiculous assumption that space is a
physical object that time is a physical
object that you can bend and they run
with and they say okay let's let's send
our probe out there see if the gyroscope
touches time
oh great i mean please conceptualize it
on the board before you send your
millions of dollars of probes out there
okay
anyways uh in science we don't test
anything
sorry okay we don't do experiments in
science we explain them that's the
difference between science and
technology okay you can do all the
experiments you want in your lab that's
fine that's technology so far all you
did is move your hands
when you come back to the office you
have to explain
how that happened
okay especially with invisible
intangible mediators that mother nature
uses that's what you gotta explain
testing testing only has to do with
persuasion convincing converting
recruiting with
belief
with religion that's what testing and
evidence have to do with okay not with
science science we don't empiricize
anything we do
we do no experiments
physics we explain
mechanisms we begin with an assumption
let us assume that light is mediated by
what a pair of twine threads that's the
assumption okay we continue with a
theory explanation okay light consists
of torsions along this dna-like entity
that's how it works in science okay so
this person says test what are you going
to test if you can't touch
and you cannot see
the rope
the mediator of light
you cannot test
because you cannot see or touch the
mediator of gravity what is the use of
going to a lab to run an experiment when
here
here's the experiment that's the only
experiment you need you let go of the
pen and it falls to the floor
i mean
did that require an act of congress or
something i mean all you get you get the
test already
so the question is if if this is the
only experiment you need
okay very expensive experiment always do
it in the presence of a relativist we
have the experiment we can do it 10
times so it's repeatable
now explain it what came in physical
contact with a pen can you see or touch
it and the answer is no
so going to the lab 10 times is not
going to help you what you need to do is
sit back
and visualize the mechanism that mother
nature is using and if you say that
nothing came in contact with a pen
you're introducing black magic you're
introducing spirits
and with that i'll see you
on